okay welcome to another edition of chess
openings explained this week is the
first week that we're going to take a
viewer submission so this is this goes
out to Mike Spence who wanted to see the
Banco gambit as as from the white side
so we're going to go over the Banco
today we're going to check it out try to
understand the different plans and
strategies around it and we're going to
focus on the fianchetto variation for
white which is one of the most solid
ways to play so we'll get this on the
board so after D for white is hoping to
play e4 and get a big center so one of
the way blacks can counter it is with
Knight f6 so right so he's fighting for
control here of the center and it white
plays the most common move here which is
c4 it's not the only move but uh white
is just gaining a little bit of space
he's going to play Knight c3 and try to
play e4 again so there's a lot of
different ways black can address this
how should he attack the center should
he give white the center when you play
for the Bangko gambit or for the the
Pannonia it starts with the move c5 so
if you're playing this with the black
side you need to know what happens if
white does in advance which is the the
most popular move if they play a move
like Knight f3 black players should be
ready because now you're you're entering
in to an English after some trades here
so black would need to know that if
you're comfortable playing this way with
white this is a good alternative maybe
your opponent as black isn't quite ready
for he's you know he only studied d5
he's not ready for that Knight f3 lines
going back into an English but the most
popular move and the one we're going to
look at today is d5 so white grabs a lot
of Center and so there's there's some
obvious pros and some some cons whenever
you move your pawns in the center you
you get stuff you get a lot of space
mostly black is unable to put his knight
on c6 which is a nice achievement but
when you move your pawns
you are weakening the dark-squared
diagonal so from the a1 to h8 this
diagonal is a little bit weaker because
you no longer have a pawn on d4 so black
wool very often fianchetto his bishop
that is so he's going to this blacks
plan just to put his Bishop over here
and that's a very nice diagonal now one
thing that they sometimes do with you're
not going to play the benoni if you're
going to if you're not gonna play the
Bangko if you're going to play the
Benoni you can expect the move X so as Y
you should know something about this
opening I'll show it only very briefly
so after you'll get this structure and
there's a lot of different plans for
white he can do a lot of different
setups here he can even do a fianchetto
system kind of like we're going to show
in the game but this this is a much
different opening and the most
aggressive plan white can try is just e
4 and F 4 and he's you know he's just
trying to crash through in the center
and just blow black off the board so
that'd be the benoni there's also
another way for black to play in this
position and that is to sacrifice upon
so the move b5 he's you know he's
offering you a pond and you don't have
to take but that's we're going to look
at at the most critical lines today so
we're going to accept the gambit we're
going to take on b5 now part of blacks
point is he's going to play a six and if
you accept which is what we're going to
check out today you're opening you know
he has the a and the B files for his
compensation so he's gonna try to get a
lot of pressure on the queenside and
show that it's enough that it's worth
upon this is one of the most respected
gambits so if you if you won't do you
want to play a gambit this is a very
good one to consider as black it's it's
not seen at the very highest level so
much but it's it's popular enough that
you know you're going to see it at the
Grandmaster level okay you don't have
two of the most popular way to decline
is just to play b6 and then and this is
a great way to play as white - you're
just not opening to a file you're giving
back the pawn at some point black will
will take and then you know you'll still
be slightly better
and you're just you know but you're not
up upon also a very aggressive player
might want to check out the lines with
with f3 because they you're just trying
to play e4 as fast as possible and these
lines are great if you're a super
tactical player and you want to get into
some some crazy lines but today we're
going to see the critical test of any
gambit is what happens if you accept it
we just we take the pawn so in this
position it looks like he's about ready
to take the pawn back and you can you
can take it right away it's considered a
little bit more accurate though to start
the plan with g6 you're going to fee and
Ketel your bishop and you're going to be
ready to castle now this doesn't it
applies to a lot of lines white black is
trying to take away a lot of lines that
don't really affect the fianchetto
player too much but one difference is
very often this rook is going to end up
on b1 and we're going to explain why
that is coming up shortly and so if
white is allowed not that these are the
best moves I'm just putting these on the
on the board for now sometimes black
will be able to play here attacking the
rook so he's waiting he's not putting
his his bishop on a6 he hasn't committed
to that plan he might go to f5 and
attack the rook and he's always trying
to provoke the movie for this is is a
good success for the the second player
here we're going to obviously the pawns
hanging here but in general if you if
you provoke efore you're going to see
we're going to show in the first game
that we look at today what happens if
white gives up the very important d3
square so that's what that's what we're
going to be checking out so we'll get
back to to our theoretical interest here
so g6 usually you play Knight c3 very
flexible and now you're ready to play
the move efore so black often now does
take you can you don't have to but he
can take right away
especially if he's expecting sort of the
classical line which begins with the
move
efore so you were prepared you play d4
that's why you put your knight on c3 you
you you do realize he's going to take
here which is the main line and you take
back
so you didn't castle but it's it's okay
you're just going to put your king
somewhere probably on g2 you can also
play h3 and get your king over to h2 but
this is considered sort of the main line
it's also a very good way to play for
white but we're going to check out what
is at least you know at the top level
the main line so it's not and again it's
not played at like the super GM level
very often but but when they do it's
usually you'll see this this feeling
kind of variation so you can play
immediately you can you can play g3
sometimes you want to start with Knight
f3 just because then they still don't
know what you're up to you're hiding
your intentions your next move still
might be e4 they have to be ready for
that but you should just haven't told
them yet what you're doing you can play
g3 occasionally you'll see games where
people maneuver their Knight to f4 but
you really don't have to do this to get
an advantage with white you can just
play a normal move just get your night
to the best square go to the normal
square and okay so black his plans for
developing he's going to develop his
bishop he's going to get his pawn out
and he's going to have this Knight
that's going to be able to come over
here and put a lot of pressure on d5 so
that's going to be one of the main
sources for black to get counter play so
white when we're playing the fianchetto
variation we're going to play the move
g3 and we're going to put our bishop on
g2 and we're not allowing this trade of
light squared bishop s' so we're keeping
more pieces on the board all right
often they'll play here it is important
you could also castle but it's important
for black to be able to have this option
as quickly as possible
he often wants to be able to put
pressure on the D pawn just so that it
limits White's options in the opening so
after some normal moves castling is an
okay move and it's played almost as much
as Knight B to d7 so you're just getting
ready you're going to play Knight to be
6 if you castle which I mean of course
it's fine sometimes you're going to let
white get this this favorable set
or after he castles he's going to get
the Queen on c2 and the rook on d1 now
that's not like it's you know a tragedy
that black has allowed the setup but
it's really nice to have the rook off of
the same diagonal as the bishop on a6
that way you know there's no you know
threats on your epon it can go to e4 at
some point when it's safe to do so and
ok so that's one possible move order but
considered best is Knight B to d7
because now the moves castling which
seems like the most normal move is
actually inaccurate here for white and
we're going to look at a game which is
this happens and black is going to
immediately get a lot of pressure on the
d5 pawn so the first game we're going to
look at is is we're going to see how
white can get into some trouble actually
if he if he doesn't know what he's doing
so considered the most accurate move
here is rook b1 which is kind of a
strange move if you've never seen it
before but the purpose is you're trying
to get this rook off the same diagonal
as the bishop so in a lot of lines
you're going to need to be able to move
your your knight or have your move yes
you're going to want to be able to play
like b3 the reason is if you castle will
show what could possibly go wrong so you
would like to play the move b3 here
because black is threatening to go here
forking two of your your pawns so you
know if you just if you pass they're
going here and they're forking some of
your pawns so it's hard to deal with
some of these these threats okay so you
want to be able to play the move b3 but
when you do this you don't want the rook
on the same diagonal as the bishop
because there's going to be some some
tricks okay so the main move is is
actually rook b1 and now White's plan
for the Queen side his ideal structure
is he's going to put upon on b3 which
controls the c-4 square and he's going
to put a pawn on a4 which controls
another very important LightSquared the
b v square and then he's going to try to
get this bishop ideally on the long
diagonal where it can test blacks bishop
the bishop on g7 is one of blacks best
pieces so white really wants to put his
bishop on the same diagonal so
eventually they get traded and it
neutralizes that bishop so okay and here
people would they Castle and we're going
to see this is sort of the starting
position of the main line here with with
rook b1 and we're going to see a couple
different plans that the black has at
his disposal mostly white is not playing
you know something in the center on the
Kings side immediately he's not going to
go try to checkmate black he is up upon
and he's going to try to keep it that
way
black will get a lot of pressure on the
Queen side like one common way to do
this is Queen a5 and rook b7 and you
have a lot of pressure on the a and B
file also he might you know load up
pressure on the d5 pawn and try to
attack the center so white really needs
to focus on neutralizing blacks threats
before he does anything of his own so
we'll see a game where white doesn't
really play as best as he could and he
he doesn't know all of the nuances and
gets into trouble in the opening now
normally I would probably take this
position and I'd show okay here's like
the three main moves in the starting
position but I thought for this lecture
in particular it'd be kind of better to
show alright this is what white can do
and go wrong and it you know what book
should white avoid and then it will show
a game of what should black avoid what
kind of things can can really wreck his
game immediately and so that's what
we're going to do so two games of people
playing badly and then we'll show a game
with people playing the main line and
going over the the main moves so okay so
without further ado we're going to go
over a game to show you what white
should avoid doing in this game white
does not play very well so he's going to
you know give away control of the d3
square and we're going to see that's the
whole emphasis of the game he loses
control of some light squares on the
Queen side and his position falls apart
quickly so here's what is to be avoided
as as white okay so we get to our our
position
um okay and so in this game White has
castled early he didn't play rook to be
one which is the most accurate move and
so we'll see the trouble that he can get
into so black is going to put a lot of
pressure on the d5 pawn immediately when
white castles now white will never be
able to do this sort of plan because the
D pawn will be hanging so he needs to
still try to play for for like rook b1
here and b3 because there's just there's
about to be be a lot of pressure
one problem too is if you play here now
this fork is is really strong because
you're going to win one of your pawns
back so and then black will actually be
slightly better but in our game rook e1
was played and White's about to play E
for so after he plays efore he really
gives away the d3 square and this is
kind of one of the most important things
you need to know if you're playing the
white side you've got to be really
really careful when you push your EEP on
because it might not look like it now
there's only a bishop that can go to d3
but black is going to try to maneuver
his knights to the d3 square and if a
knight or a bishop lands on d3 you can
be in a lot of trouble also the other
night is it's able he can get there too
he can take a slightly different route
but you'll have two knights that can
potentially go to d3 which is also
important because if you put a knight
here and we trade one of the knights and
you have to take back with the bishop
it's not going to be as good so you want
both of your nice to be able to go to d5
so that even if we trade one you'll have
one of them that's able to go to d3 okay
and that's what black does immediately
so he's heading towards the d3 square if
we passed it one wouldn't really make
sense to do it immediately because then
we would just be able to trade and you'd
have to you know take back with a bishop
and you don't want your Bishop on d5 you
want your knight there so he's not
threatening to do it immediately but
wait here kind of has a problem black is
getting ready to play Knight to c4 but
you can't stop him from from from going
there because this guy would be hanging
it's important to notice the bishop on
that long diagonal you never want to
forget he's there because he's one of
blacks best pieces so since you can't
play b3 right away he played the Queen
to c2 which okay protects the night and
now you can play b3 now this game wasn't
the most accurate played by both sides
even though the player with the black
pieces was like 25 70 so he but he still
he didn't really come up with this plan
in the game so this immediately is just
a great move and then you you get one of
your Knights either Knight to this
square and you get a knight on d3 so
this should be considered immediately
but instead Queen to c7 was played and
now white should play b3 he should you
know be stopping that Knight from going
to c4 but he didn't do that either he
played a strange move Bishop to e3 it's
it's very unusual to see the bishop on
that square normally this Bishop will go
to any other square often he's going to
go to be to after you know you've played
the move b3 because then you're on the
same diagonal as black start squared
Bishop and you're trying to neutralize
him whenever the Queen goes to a5 you'll
see that often the bishop is going to go
to d2 so that you know there's some
threads you have a bishop on the same
diagonal as their queen occasionally
you'll see the bishop go to f4 the point
here is maybe you want to play the move
e5 and then the bishop would be useful
there you can also imagine that a bishop
might go to g5 where you have a little
bit of pressure on a pond and if black
doesn't have his dark squared Bishop you
can even imagine that the bishop would
go to h6 but III it's just not the
square you ever want to go to with this
bishop in this opening so I can't think
of another game where this happened it's
just it's unusual and it shows that
white doesn't really understand the
opening okay and now again he has
allowed this move which which wasn't
played but now it's even stronger
because okay you got you got some good
squares that you're looking at and okay
even have pressure here you're going to
get
in here but okay here they're going to
take the bishop or you're going to
maneuver a knight to d3 so this would
have been excellent for black instead
rook F to b8 was played which is a good
idea in general these these rooks are
mighty nice on the a and B file because
there's a there's a lot of pressure
going on here which is nice but it
wasn't as good as Knight to c4
immediately okay and now a big of a
mistake
so he's relinquished his control over
the e5 square and now we're going to see
it d3 is really weak and black is about
to get all of his pieces in there and Oh
whites and whites in a lot of trouble
here black is significantly better here
he comes again you can never highlight
d3 enough that's where the knight is
going and then white did something
unusual he still should do something
like trying to make d3 work but he
played f4 which he's just inviting the
knight in so he's begging the night to
go to the square it wanted to go to
anyway so not the best okay we're
attacking this rook we have a lot of
pressure on this beep on you know
there's like rooks and bishops there's
lots of pressure going on all over that
the Queen side so he puts his rook on b1
I'm kind of protecting his pawn and now
we'll see black do a lot of good
maneuvering he now wants to not have the
night there he wants to have a bishop on
d3 because there's a queen and a rook
lined up on the same diagonal here so a
very nice move Knight to be for
attacking the Queen
so always play Queens a d1 and now the
bishop gets to come in and we're in a
significant amount of trouble as as
white here he can consider even giving
up the exchange because he isn't that
much trouble he can just let black take
and then okay admit that he's a lot
worse he didn't in this game he saved
the rook which is actually a big blunder
so I'll ask the audience the first
question and it's a really tough one
Black has a unexpectedly good move in
this position so I'll give you a chance
to try to find it
there's a very nice combination that you
might not even think to look for so and
black was a very strong Grandmaster and
he didn't find it Oh which one this work
on day eight okay I mean this work is is
nice I mean yeah it is nice that maybe
we do need to identify these sorts of
things about the position
Brooke is there so in some lines he
might take on a to write that's that's
definitely a thing that might happen and
some lines the night might take on a two
but uh but we'll give you just a couple
more seconds here to see if you can find
it it's a very difficult move to find
because it's kind of a thing that can
get black into a lot of trouble and
we'll see this getting black into a lot
of trouble in our next game the best
move here is actually to take this night
and white is in a lot of trouble as
black you don't want to give up your
best piece you're awesome Bishop on g7
just for a night unless you have some
really good reason so black better have
a really good reason first of all if you
take with the pawn
okay we take on a two and where does
where does this guy go you know you're
sure about to win in exchange and your
pieces are still running wild all over
the Queen side here so slightly better
is to take with the rook and now what
would black play here
all right we got some some shoulder
shrugs so hey we'll see we'll give you a
little bit of time perhaps somebody can
come to our rescue but who Hey
right yeah yeah the guy that can answer
the question he left so I'll give you
the answer all right the best move here
is Knight to a4 you know you're just
you're kicking these guys around a lot
now you're also attacking this pawn so
it's it's a fork if you try to stay
where you can protect it so you can
protect it here you can protect it here
which obviously we'll run into some
issues I better hit new variation or who
knows what the computers going to do if
you play rook b3 your rook is going to
get trapped I'm not saying that's not
what boys best move is here maybe it is
but you're going to have to give up the
exchange this way your rook is trapped
okay if you go back let's say we want to
protect our rook well now you're just
you're just in a lot of trouble these
these pieces are starting to crush you
you can move your queen and I'm just
taking all of your stuff and my pieces
are still awesome on the Queen side and
I have a lot of threats and you know I'm
attacking all of your pieces and my
Knights keep attacking all of your rooks
so this would be just horrendous for
white but uh okay this opportunity in
this position was was missed because
it's not often you would think about
taking this night with your bishop
so we'll see what black actually played
he played nine c4 which black is still a
little bit better now but it seems odd
that in this position you would trade
this night for this or for this night
because all right this your night on b6
is looking pretty good it has potential
to come into a 4 or c4 at the right
moment and the night on d2 is a little
bit clumsy it's it's not obvious what
it's doing in there so like c4 not the
most accurate though black is still
feeling pretty comfortable here so after
a trade now how should white continue
probably with the move be
three kicking the bishop back so he
finally got the move B three in and at
some point he'll he'll consider playing
to move a four so I mean black is still
doing pretty well but he's he didn't win
the game instantly so he missed a pretty
good chance first he kicks the night
away which again is strange he's again
inviting the knight into the square it
wants to go too so a three again was not
the most precise move so I've
highlighted d3 again because that's
going to keep given white headaches this
is all a result of him playing efore if
you didn't play the movie 4 you saw have
your pawn here this sort of thing will
never happen to you because you're your
pawn is protecting the d3 square which
is like the most important square you
know to know about when you play this
opening
all right the rook is attacked it's hard
to see what what to do obviously if you
you move away you're dropping one of
your pieces because the bishop is still
on g7 and if you play what was played in
the game rook to c2 you're dropping one
of your pawns
so black gets his pawn back but he has
tons of pressure this guy is still
really weak it's not obvious what
white's pieces are doing and he doesn't
have any serious attack you know he's
trying to do this sort of thing with his
pawns I mean it seems kind of impressive
that he got all of his pawns here but
you don't want to try to go for an
attack immediately with white you want
to stop black from doing all this stuff
to you and you know and then only later
maybe you'll play f4 and E 4 and try to
get a 5 in and start attacking on the
Kings side ok so another unfortunate
move but it's tough because your knight
is attacked twice this move though
however loses instantly and so this one
people in here might be able to solve
what is a blacks best move in this
position so right so we just moved our
bishop off of this diagonal
right that's fine there's a lot of
incredibly intelligent people here so
I'm sure Rock we're banking on a one
person to come up with the answer here
okay so you moved your bishop off the
same diagonal as White's King the
crusher is Bishop to d4 which was played
in black and white decided to lose the
quick way he went here and now again a
tactic a tactic so simple even Bensimon
can find it Knight f2 and that white
resigned here so right so we're forking
to pieces so we're going to win the
Queen and the game is over for white you
might be wondering what happens if King
f1 okay if King f1 all right now we got
some serious people in here now are
getting serious if King f1 there's a lot
of good moves
obviously there's there's a lot of
excellent discoveries with the bishop
here the most crushing is taking on f4
so what happens in this position if we
keep trying to run we go to e1 so what
would what would black want to play here
we got a lot of firepower in the
audience now so we're going to get some
of these Bensimon Knight takes G to
checkmate so yeah these bishops are
awesome
the knight is given the check okay so
your best move would be to go here which
is also resigned a bull because you're
losing your queen and if you take this
night it just keeps getting worse he
takes your rook so that was an example
of what not to do with white white gave
away the d3 square and you went for a
big attack on the King side and ignored
what black was doing because he
sacrificed material on the Queen side
black is going to get really active play
on the Queen side immediately so
need to be really careful and try to
understand what black is trying to do
and stop him from doing that before you
think about marching your pawns in the
center so now we're going to take a look
at a different game where black makes
some big mistakes so in the game we're
about to watch black is going to make
one of the the key mistakes that you can
make is black giving away your Bishop on
g7 just to win upon so we're going to
check that out so here we go we'll get
back to our our position again if you're
if you're just joining us we're doing
the Bangko gambit the fianchetto
variation okay and g3 was preferred
before Knight f3
excellent okay so we get to our position
and the most accurate move Knight B to
d7 was played in this game White's going
to play a little bit better
what's the main move here that we
discussed we looked at castling so we
know that that's the wrong answer what's
the best move for white here
if you got it excellent yeah so route b1
now that you're off this diagonal
White's going to be able to play moves
like b3 and Bishop b2 all right so black
goes immediately for pressure on the d5
pond all right so there's there's no
threat at the moment it's attacked twice
it's protected twice so we can spend a
move trying to get our Bishop to b2 okay
both players castled and all right now
we see a very common idea so this is an
important middle game plan that we want
to understand for black the knight is I
mean it's strange why would you retreat
well it's going to put a lot more
pressure on the center so this is a very
common maneuver you go to e8 to c7 you
put a lot of pressure on d5 also when
you play this move you are attacking our
knight in this position so I mean I've
seen people do this sort of thing where
they just forget that Black has that
dark squared Bishop and then you feel
really silly when they take it you
always want to be aware that's where he
is so white defends the pawn in a the
most logical way he puts the bishop on
b2 all right
black wasn't joking that's his plan he's
got a lot of pressure and there's
different ways that he can continue to
put pressure on the D pawn for example
he could bring his bishop back and he
can also consider another popular
maneuver for black that you know would
kind of surprise you if you haven't seen
it before
rook a7 with the idea of Queen to e8 and
then the Queen would be putting pressure
on the D pawn
so this is something we kind of want to
be aware of as black okay so you'll
notice okay where he is attacking this
pawn twice we're defending it twice but
now he can take if he wants to so this
is a decision the black you know has to
think about very very carefully do you
want to take the bishop to give away
your best piece your bishop on g7 just
to win upon sometimes you do and in the
their game we saw we're trading the
bishop for the night would have been an
excellent move in that particular
situation based on that concrete
variation but here it's very inadvisable
and we'll see why because black took the
knight now one thing I've learned about
this variation from experience is
whenever they do this sort of thing they
take your knight on c3 it's pretty much
never right to take with the Queen you
always want to take with the bishop and
I just know that from experience even
though black is going to have to play a
move like f6 which is kind of ugly his
next move is going to come with a tempo
on your queen and you're going to make
another Queen move so even though it
looks appealing because you're
threatened checkmate and you're forcing
f6 it's almost better almost always
better to take with the bishop okay
so black takes his pawn and then white
makes a surprising move you might expect
it okay the Bishop's going to retreat
and then you know he's going to go from
there but he played a different move so
what amazing moved in white play in this
position all right right so now we're
getting really serious in here Queen h6
dropping the bishop so for the other
people in the class if we take the
bishop what was White's plan why did you
give away a piece because shoulder shrug
oh yeah excellent Knight g5 and I dare
you to protect this pond so you're going
to get checkmated so that the threat on
the King side is so strong that you
don't have time to take the bishop so
there's a couple different ways you can
try to defend in the game
'if I've was chosen not a lot better is
Knight to f6 if Knight to f6
you can still play Knight to g5 and now
your threat is to first take the knight
and then you're threatening the pawn on
g7 again so you'd almost be compelled to
play a move
either a five or put a night on e eight
where you're defending your other night
so whenever they play e5 we're going to
answer it with f4 because when we take
this pawn now this rook is on the F file
and that's going to be a really strong
piece so that's how we're going to meet
it whenever they play e5 so if they play
Knight to e8 with the point okay if you
give up your Bishop I'm defending and I
still have control of the g7 pawn White
has a really good move here so you can
take this and win in exchange which is
good for white but it's better to stop
on c6 and it's kind of funny now you're
threatening to take this Knight which
means you're threatening to take this
knight which means you're threatening to
pawn on g7 and so again you'd have to
play a move like 'if I've we're going to
play f4 we're going to open up the F
file and okay this is very bad for black
and it's very similar to what happened
in the game so we'll check out what
happened in the game 'if I've was played
immediately so okay we make our threat
we got a lot of pressure here so he has
to go back and defend so since you know
what I just said
what did white play here
alright let a lot of finger-pointing
who's going to come up with it
anybody yeah excellent f for the pawns
on we're going to open the F file or
it's going to be great
so black tries to trade for this night a
good idea but now we're going to open
the F file so all right we're
threatening this he's going to take our
night on g5 to stop us from immediately
mating him and now we have some
interesting choices but okay we're going
to take the night with the pawn
threatening checkmate again this time we
have a lolis mate potential on g7 so you
have to guard that Square as black the
best way to do that ninety six now white
just wins from here as you can imagine
okay
a lot of these these pieces are really
good even this guy's good so what is the
winning plan here for white we got a
really good maneuver
have you got it we'll get four excellent
awesome so you can't take our rook
checkmate in the plan is is you know
pretty simple you're going to bring your
rook over and you're going to threaten
the g-seven pond yet again a very common
theme so in the game black took on e to
his point is he's going to bring his
bishop back and try to defend it's not
going to work so white goes through with
this plan black blocks and okay so
what's the way to win here
so why it still needs to attack find
some good attacking moves but if you
find the right move here then you're
going to win the game awesome right
and he sees the follow-up so he took
here and after Bishop e4 black player
had enough he gave up you you might
think it's matin one but black can live
for for one more move and then okay then
he gets checkmated so okay so I'm very
good in bye-bye white and it shows you
the dangers if you're the black player
if you give up your Bishop on g7 you
really got to worry about your dark
squares you gave up your dark squared
bishop in this game and then you got
made it on the dark squares so alright
so I was excellent now we're going to
look at our last game of the day and
we're going to show you a game where
people both are playing well so two
really strong players and we'll see some
of the the main motifs when when you're
playing the main main line okay so here
we go again we'll get back to our
position the Bangko gambit all right so
in this game castling was preferred over
Knight B to d7 so okay white white
castles and now so right so he does have
some of these ideas that could
potentially happen with you know Queen
c2 rook d1 but it's probably better
first you play the move rook b1 so that
you're able to play the move b3 which is
kind of the the essential point of a
voice play here now this is considered
to be the main
fine it's a the most trodden path so we
we put our Queen here which is excellent
because you have a lot of pressure on
the a file but also it prevents b3
because of the night that would be
hanging so white should protect his
night and we wanted to put our Queen or
actually sorry whenever they put their
Queen on a5 we almost always put our
bishop on d2 and now sometimes there's
going to be tricks immediately there's
no good discoveries so if we waste a
move with black there's there's no good
discoveries on the Queen so because you
would just lose your pawn so you don't
really have a threat of any discovery at
the moment but it might be useful later
on so black can't afford to keep the
Queen there there's there's no threat so
in this game after Bishop to d2 black
got his other rook into the action again
lots of pressure on these pawns here
okay so as White Queen to c2 you know we
might be thinking about rook to d1 at
some point also if we ever move our be
pawn now our knight is protected twice
by the bishop and the Queen all right in
black puts pressure on the D pawn he
sorry again I think the key focus here
is the D pawn he's not threatening to
win it immediately so again I had just
waste a move there's no threat to win
this pawn because of the discovery on
the Queen here we would take this and we
got threats on the Queen so we would
just win then that night there so why
doesn't have to do anything rash like
play E for and give up the d3 square he
can take his time play the move b3 he
kind of would like to play the move a4
because then he'd be threatening if we
waste a move to play Knight b5 and in
the queen is is you know getting trapped
kind of so that's the kind of move he
would like to make but uh okay the
Knights going to be able to come into c4
so we don't want to give away that
square so we play the move b3 and if we
get another turn we're going to play a
four which threatens Knight to b5
trapping the Queen
so black stops white from doing that he
plays Queen to a three so that you can't
play the move a for yourself now this
Bishop even though he's already moved he
really belongs on this diagonal over
here so we're going to try to get it on
the same diagonal his black star squared
Bishop so Bishop to c1 was preferred and
after the Queen moved he kicked the
Queen away so alright which is a good
move the Queen kind of has to go tone
the only square that she can go to here
g4 and that's not really where you
expect to see the Queen in this line
because black isn't attacking on the
Kings side the Queen is now going to
have to like reorganize herself by going
backwards and getting back on the Queen
side where she belongs
okay so the pawn was attacked twice the
white defended it again and now the
Queen retreats so we see that the Queen
going backwards here and h3 a useful
move were taken away the the g4 square
just in case black was thinking about
doing this maneuver as he likes to do
and you know we're taking we're trying
to make sure the knight never lands on
e5 okay so black has to come up with
some plan he's kind of stuck here
White's position is very solid he's
thinking maybe okay I'll go here put a
little bit of pressure on the the b-pawn
but white is clearly better and what
happens a lot in these lines is you uh
you are you get a position where you can
kind of do nothing for a long time and
if you just keep doing nothing you don't
really do any active plans you don't try
to go crazy and nuts and try to push it
in the center you're just going to be
better forever and ever and ever and
then sometimes black cracks so that's
what happens in this game so that's kind
of a biggest secret in chess is don't do
anything and we'll see why do a really
good job of just kind of maneuvering
slowly slowly improving his position and
black kind of runs out of a plan here he
doesn't come up with anything useful for
the rest of this game here so II for Ken
black make use of the d3 square
probably not we have the c-4 square
under control so this maneuver isn't
going to happen we the other night can
potentially go to e5 but if you can only
get one night there white will always
have this guy waiting to be able to
trade for them so this is an example of
when you can move your EEP on just
because you have a good enough control
over d3 all right black should try
anyway so now in the other game we saw
somebody put their knight on D 2 and
then they got into a lot of trouble on
the d3 square so this Knight has to stay
put he better he better stay there
so Bishop f4 is white thinking about
playing e5 that's one of the things he
can consider and again pretty much
anywhere other than here is going to be
a good square you can easily consider a
move like a 4 or Bishop e2 those moves
are all good as well Bishop f4 is is
fine black doesn't really know what to
do he goes here he's got some pressure
but White has everything under control
and now a really nice move that uh that
I like is coming up first alright he's
threatening he's going to he's thinking
about it he's making black have to think
what happens if he plays a 5 ok so he
kind of prevents it he puts the Queen
here the Queen's is guarding the square
and he has a black thinking about what
he's going to do and now white can
either try to play in the center or he
can try to make use of his two pawns
over here and this is what will often
happen and I really like the way white
for the rest of the game plays he
advances all of his pawns slowly he
makes sure he takes control over the
squares the pawns need to go to and he
fights against the blockades that black
might set up so we'll see that here he
starts with her move a4 at some point
he's thinking about a5 at some point
he's thinking about b4 but after this
move I mean it which doesn't really do
anything black doesn't have a good plan
here that's that's his problem
white plays a really excellent move that
I've seen in some high-level games so
this is a good move too
if you're white black sometimes is
thinking about playing the move see for
himself but if you play the move Knight
to a2 whenever if c4 has ever played you
play b4 now this pawn is protected
enough so you can just keep expanding
and this would be really terrible for
black now these pawns are coming fast so
Knight a - it might be strange but this
is one of those ideas you can keep in
their back of your mind when you're
playing this opening it's something that
actually happens quite frequently okay
Black is just shuffling back and forth
he's not really doing anything
so what could think about going crazy in
the center but also he can take his time
and continue to do nothing because black
isn't doing anything himself so he can
slowly improve slowly make it possible
to play moves on the Queen side here so
rook to c1 now there's a lot of pressure
here so if ever you play the move b4 you
wouldn't be able to take with the C pawn
because now you have two heavy pieces on
the C file so okay so he's thinking
about playing the move b4 so black gets
out of the way he moves his Queen back
and it's all revolving around when is
white gonna play before he can do it
whenever he's ready and black is just
waiting so he takes his time Bishop d2
now he's really controlling all the
squares his pawns might need to go to
next the only reason that I think black
played this move here is provocation he
didn't have to play this move he's
obviously encouraging white to play a5
but it's it's not obvious that that's
the blacks advantage he's provoking
white to play a move that he wants to
play anyway
the knight has to go back to the only
square he can go to and white is ready
to play b4 so he's done it he now he's
getting serious about this pawn over
here and it's funny because normally
it's black that gets all of his play
over on the Queen side but he fooled
around a little bit too much she did an
exotic Queen maneuver early on he didn't
really get any of his typical play going
and so now here comes white he's
steamrolling ahead neither player really
wants to take the pawn in this situation
because taking will improve one of
whites pieces also if it's your turn and
you you take here well then you're
helping blacks tonight improve so
neither player thinking about taking the
pawns here
what white needs to do is somehow find a
way to take control over the b5 where
that's where he wants to play next so
night a7 okay
and he takes so that does give the black
a good square for his night and now how
to make progress how do we get this guy
look there's a lot of pieces in the way
so what's what's going to happen here
we'll see so he's fighting against the
blockade the next square he needs his
pawn to go to is a six so we attack the
the bishop and it's hard to think what
should you do with your bishop
he comes up with kind of an interesting
plan I guess he puts his Bishop on e2
and then he's going to take this knight
and white really wants that to happen
then he can get control of the light
squares so he just put his Bishop back
and he said go on take my knight so when
black did take now this Bishop is going
to come back and he's going to have
control over these these light squares
that the pawn needs so now he's fighting
for a six he's got to get his pawn to a6
alright so he's taking his time he's not
letting you know black get anything
going he's about ready to play a six
okay and this is kind of nice as well
denied is the guard of a six so he's
fighting against the piece that's
attacking a six so he trades the night
that way he can you know get the square
for his knight and now here white could
play a little bit better of course you
should always play Queen d1 which is the
best move here but instead he took all
right so black took and now right you
can't take the rook of course because
let's never forget about this guy but a
queen c4 again
Queen d1 was was an excellent move and
okay what's going on here
so black does some threats but alright
but now this guy is going to move and
then our pawn is going to try to go like
this alright and then black gets a
little bit cute he's you know thinking
here that the tactics are going to work
for him but they actually don't so here
what I guess I'll ask the class what
should white play in this position
because black is getting a little bit
fancy you know he's dreaming about
taking here with check and it's
complicated does this move work that's
sort of the main question here can you
give up the rook for two pieces of
course when your queen ends up on d4
there's going to be some threats so it's
actually a little bit more complicated
than it might seem at first so does work
takes d4 work alright we got a vote for
no he did it he took on d4 so after he
takes now it appears that our bishop is
hanging which is true but also take note
of their Knight over there which is
attacked it's tricky when they take our
Bishop though if we just take the knight
he's taking with check and okay we've
we've lost an exchange here somehow so
what is a what did white actually play
here we need a better move than just
taking the knight immediately
excellent Bishop to c3 threatening some
checkmates on either one of these
squares so that's the most important
thing Black has to deal with he has to
stop getting checkmated so f6 kind of an
ugly move to have to play but okay now
the bishop is safe we can safely take
the knight and now we're getting really
close to getting this guy all the way
home all right he attacks our bishop and
so we move it and now it's it's going to
become a question where should white get
his knight this move isn't necessarily a
good one
for black because sometimes you know the
Queen is coming in sometimes the knight
is going to find its way to this nice
square or this nice square you can
imagine the knight going here where it's
it's can go to either one of these
squares and there they both look like a
pretty nice place for a knight also nice
is the e6 square getting really close to
the black King and there's nobody on the
eighth-ranked so the Queen is getting
ready to infiltrate so all right what
what to do black got a little bit
desperate and you he's going to take the
knight in a second
white is getting ready to you know make
some some big threats here the Queen is
coming in and you're going to start to
get into trouble
the knight has a good square so he felt
compelled to take the knight now we're
up a piece and we have this pawn so the
game is practically over here by taking
the bishop it's of course now white is
actually going to be able to promote the
Queen so after taking I kind of like
what white did he just ignored that the
pawn on d5 is hanging what all you need
to do is go make a queen and after let's
see so you don't have to take the pawn
if you play Queen e1 though it's only
one check we have this pawn protected
and you're not stopping us from making a
queen but okay he gave up his d5 pawn
and now he played a nice move Queen to
b7 so now you can't trade Queens because
then my pawn is going to promote and
after the checks now you got nothing
you've run out it's nice that the Queen
is
the same diagonal as the king and okay
black resigned because you but whites
just going to make another Queen and so
the game is over
so hopefully that was a good
introduction for those of you that are
thinking about playing the Banco gambit
or want to play it a bit more keep
sending in your submissions because next
week maybe I'll pick the opening that
you choose so please remember to like to
comment send your suggestions and I will
see you next week